okay got a voicemail today on our
voicemail line two one nine two david p
it's about equality of outcome let's
take a listen hey David I just wanted to
kind of maybe take a little issue with
the whole concept of the left looking
for equality of outcome and not a
quality opportunity I I think that to
have a certain level of equality of
opportunity there it has to be certain
outcomes that are provided to all like
everyone has to have the outcome of
being able to go to the doctor when
they're sick everyone needs to have the
outcome of having access to a quality
education for there to be opportunity
equality of opportunity I don't know
those are really opposing forces and the
way you kind of ended a little bit in
your uh you know why you're not a
socialist video yeah okay I think that I
just disagree with the language yeah the
being able to go to the doctor is not an
outcome
it's the opportunity having the
opportunity to go to the doctor with
your sick I just think that you're
mistaking what are outcomes and what are
opportunities yeah being healthy would
be the outcome
same thing on education right yeah I
feel like the opportunity to go to
school right that's the opportunity yes
being successful that's the outcome
exactly yeah I think it's just
misunderstanding maybe some of the
semantics and and the language around it
I think some of the outcomes that you're
talking about the outcomes will
naturally be slightly less uneven if
opportunity is actually equal and that's
where I think we should be focusing but
I don't know if maybe I'm
misunderstanding exactly what the caller
met we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about Elon Musk calling
one of the Thai cave divers a pedophile
and now apologizing for it we will also
talk about a new report from up the road
at MIT which says that a quadrillion
tons of diamonds lie between ninety and
a hundred and fifty feet below the
earth's surface and CBS has fired two
employees who were filmed calling 911
who they believed was using a
counterfeit coupon for adult
incontinence products a very very
bizarre story get access to the bonus
show two ways to do it become a member
at WWE at medCom coupon code is
available vote soon eighteen option two
become a patron for at least five bucks
a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show